Cocinando por Primera vez independizada.
No he cocinado en mi vida,
así que a esta serie la vamos a llamar
cocina con niniba sin saber cocinar.
Hoy voy a cocinar tortilla de papa.
Lo que me manda a hacer es cortar las papas.
Mi pregunta es, ¿cuántas papas tengo que cortar?
No sé en qué forma hay que cortarla, tío.
Oye, fuera broma,
¿las papas en Madrid cómo las hacen de piedra?
No se parte.
1 vez tengamos las papas peladas hay que lavarlas
y ahora vamos a poner a calentar el aceite.
¿Cuánta cantidad de aceite tengo que poner?
Nos inventamos.
Mientras están haciendo las papas vamos a coger 1 Plato
y servilleta.
Dice Google que si ponemos el Plato con la servilleta
y ponemos las papas,
a las papas se le VA el aceite y quedan superchachi.
Creo que es buen momento para echar Sal, ¿no?
Ahora sí que están perfectas para quitarlas.
Yo creo que así no era, tío.
Acabo de hacer papas fritas por la puta Cara,
es que no entiendo qué acabo de hacer ahora
lo que vamos a hacer es partir la cebollita en cuadraditos.
¿Ahora lo metemos en el sartén
y ahora qué hago?
Ay, mi Madre se me acaba de quemar la cebolla.
Dejamos la tortilla sin cebolla. Mejor
estoy añadiendo 2 huevos más porque creo que
en la receta decían 4 y yo puse 2 porque era más chiquitita
la tortilla, pero no tiene nada que ver,
es momento de darle ¡Vuelta a la tortilla!
Le voy a Dar vuelta a la tortilla,
la voy a liar, ¿no?
Bueno chavales, es hora de probarla.
¡Abajo me quedó perfecta para ser la Primera! ¡Genial!
1 6 de 10, fácil